alright guys
I tried one of the viral micro curling wands I've seen on TikTok
and here's my experience I have very
very straight hair so I was skeptical that this would even work for me
but I was gonna try it anyway
so I sectioned off my hair
and then I took a pretty small pieces and wrapped them around
this particular one gets really hot
so I did not let it sit at all
as soon as I was done wrapping
I released it it gave me these super
super tight bouncy curls
and so I just kept doing it on my whole head
I also film this in the kids playroom
so that's why there are some toys in the background
anyway I have very straight and fine hair
but I have a lot of it so it took me a little while
and then this is kind of what it looked like after
I have never ever seen my hair anywhere close to this curly
so it was honestly so unexpected
I brushed it out and I know it looks super crazy here
but hear me out I brush it out
and then I got some hair oil
ran it through my fingers
and this is how it turned out
and I really really
really loved it I believe this one is 3 8 7 inch
and this is the best price I have found for them so far
here's my before and after go check them out